director and writers of via Coppola
received critical acclaim in 1999 for
her debut movie The Virgin Suicides
well she went on to win an Academy Award
for Best Original Screenplay with her
second movie lost in translation
Coppola continued to make her mark on
Hollywood movies like the biopic Marie
Antoinette and the crime drama The Bling
Ring her new thriller the beguiled
follows a group of women at an all-girls
boarding school during the Civil War it
stars Nicole Kidman Kirsten Dunst and
Elle Fanning what a cast their sheltered
lives are disrupted after they'd taken
an injured enemy soldier he's portrayed
by Colin Farrell is your leg paining you
so well I hear numbness would be more
grave indeed there's some brandy if you
wish oh no that would be a pleasure I
stopped being offered for your pleasure
only for your comfort
yes ma'am I must remind you corporal
McBurney you are not a guest here you're
a most unwelcome visitor and we do not
propose to entertain you well I wouldn't
expect a man although you'll find them
easily yes Sofia Coppola welcome to
studio 57 we're delighted to have you
here congratulations on the beguile
thank you and a big award and Khan
recently so this was really this is
really such a very special movie because
you don't know a who's being beguiled
and Colin Farrell said that the violence
of the human heart is always interesting
you said the dynamic between men and
women is interesting to set the scene
for us about what is happening here yeah
the story's about it takes place in a
girls school in the South during the
Civil War and they it's a group of women
living together and it was interesting
to me because it's women of different
ages from 12 to 4 days and and they take
in a enemy soldier after not seeing a
man for a long time and I think just the
power between male men and women which
we can all relate to is at the heart of
the story an attention is immediate yes
immediate is Aurora okay I really wanted
to feel the tension and feel the heat of
the south and
I keep the tension and suspense I've had
directors tell me that that casting is
80% of making a good movie how did you
go about cashing this thing yeah I loved
working with Kirsten Dunst in the past
and Elle Fanning so I asked them to come
back and then I always admired Nicole
Kidman so I was really happy to have
such great women together and then we
had to find a man that could handle all
these late you wrote the screenplay with
Nicole Kidman in mind what did you see
in her that you knew you wanted her for
this movie I mean she's such an
incredible actress and I think this
character had to be a strong woman but
also very feminine and delicate and she
could also make her human and
sympathetic and bring so much to making
her feel like a real woman and then you
have them take etiquette classes they're
the cast was saying you had edit classes
and you had them take corset training
lessons we did a lot of getting in there
we took we were prepared before the
shooting and they were the corsets and
how to etiquette advisor and a dance
teacher and a sewing teacher just to try
to understand what it was like for women
living at that time like what because
you found a book that had unusual
etiquette lessons that we that don't
relate to us today what did you what
give us an example of that yeah this is
very extreme idea of femininity and
being a lady and that you have to be
very modest and always appealing to men
and makeup is vulgar and so this whole
idea of how women were supposed to be
for men at that time and then they found
themselves at war time with no men
around and just the role of women at
that time I'm sure you've been asked as
a thousand times but I loved your father
yeah no tell me what he's taught you
about being a good director oh I mean
I've learned everything from my father I
think the best thing is he brought
brought me and my brother on set we
spent a lot of time on his SATs and just
learning how to make foam and he's so
passionate and curious about filmmaking
and just and can't be around and without
wanting to make films and about being an
artist he always encouraged me to make
films that I felt personally connected
to and you show him an early cut I
always like to show it to him before I
locked the cut he always has great ideas
just to make sure to get his blessing
I've read that you said a remake was a
bad word in your house and this is a
remake of sorts yeah why was it a bad
word yeah my dad always said oh remake
is the only reason for remake us to make
money you know why would anyone do that
and
and so I would never think should we
make a film but this premise was so
interesting there was a don segal film
in the early 70s starring Clint Eastwood
and I and it's told from the male point
of view and I thought it'd be so
interesting to me tell this story from
the women character or women directors
having a moment at this time we had
patty Jenkins here last week before the
huge success of Wonder Woman abran
Duvernay is doing wrinkle in time do you
feel that now women are finally getting
there just do it feels like a really
exciting time because people are talking
so much about it and really valuing that
the female audience is an important one
too quick daddy thank you very nice to
meet you Sofia congratulations
the beguil'd opens in select cities
Friday and nationwide on June 30th